- You look beautiful!
- So do you.
I was watching backstage
and I was like, I would wear that.
- Oh my God.
- I was coveting you.
- I love all the bright colors.
Obviously the set has bright colors.
But this is gorgeous.
- Thank you so much.
- I love this number.
- I like a pant, you know?
- I do too.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you can Sharon Stone
without Sharon Stoning.
- 100%.
- Exactly.
- Sharon Pebble, you know what I mean?
(Kelly laughing)
Instead of a stone.
- You're witty.
Oh my gosh.
Well I haven't seen you.
I went to go visit "The
Superstore" with the teachers.
- That's right.
- So I haven't seen you
since then.
Yes.
- Oh my gosh, it was so cute.
We were waiting and we were
in the middle of shooting
and so they're like, "Oh, just
go over to the other stage
"and wait for Kelly Clarkson to come
"and surprise all these music teachers."
- Yeah.
- But the cameras are on us.
We're all ready to go, we're waiting.
And America just turns to me.
I had no idea what was going on.
And she was like,
"Are we supposed to pretend
we're not losing our minds
"that we're about to meet Kelly Clarkson?"
- Oh, are you serious?
- Yeah, and she played
it off so well right?
- Oh my god, she played it off so well.
I wouldn't even have know she knew a song.
- Oh no, she's obsessed.
- What?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Like legit.
And literally you'd come
in and she was like,
"Hi, blah, blah, blah, whatever."
Then she turned to me and be like.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh, she kept her cool so well.
- And towards the end
you said something about,
"You guys should all come
visit us on the show sometime."
She literally, I don't think
you heard her, she went,
"Yeah, you know, be friends."
(laughing and applauding)
Oh my god, it was so cute!
Legit!
- Have you ever?
That just blows my mind, I didn't know.
Have you ever just lost it
when you met someone and you were like,
"Wait, that was not a cool moment."
- Oh, yes.
- Me too.
- So many times.
I think the most memorable would be,
this was my first movie
role I ever booked.
It was in a film called
"Lars and the Real Girl"
starring Canada's
sweetheart, Ryan Gosling.
- Oh, that's how I know,
I was like, I know that movie.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, so I'm Canadian
and I was still living
in Canada at the time.
So it was day one of
the entire production.
It wasn't just my first day,
'cause I had a smaller part.
It's the first day of everything,
so there's kind of a
buzz around everybody,
'cause I know all the
other smaller part actors.
We all know each other.
And we're like, "Oh my gosh, Ryan Gosling.
"What's this gonna be?"
And then he shows up
and he had gained a bunch
of weight for the role
and had grown this mustache.
- And then that's the
day "The Notebook" died?
- Right!
(laughing)
Yeah, 100%.
And so but there's a hush
around 'cause it's Ryan Gosling
and even with everything
you're still like,
"Oh my god, come on."
And so we did a couple of rehearsals
and then we were being
sent back to our trailers
as happens.
And I was walking in
front of a friend of mine,
a lady named Aurora,
and I turned back as she was talking to me
and she's like, "Oh my gosh.
"Even with the weight,
even with the mustache,
"he's so hot."
But what she didn't know was Ryan Gosling
was right behind her.
- No!
- And I wanted to be a good friend
but I also was like,
I can't show him that I'm showing her.
So my way of handling
this was just speeding up.
I was like, I just gotta
walk as fast as I can
and I'm like, "Uh-huh, uh-huh."
And I'm walking fast, and I'm walking fast
and I get to a door.
And I go to push the door
and I hit it 'cause it was a pull.
(laughing)
- Oh!
- And so I smash into this door so hard
and I turned around to see
Ryan Gosling in full costume,
full get-up, method actor, super serious,
just laughing, just
outward laughing at me.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, that was a low.
That was a low.
- That was a low!
(laughing)
Have you ever done that, Jerry?
Have you ever just lost it?
- Embarrassed myself
in front of people?
- Embarrassed yourself like--
- Yeah, usually every morning at 10 a.m.
Yeah, in front of a whole nation.
- Sure, sure.
- So I'm used to humiliation.
- Oh my God.
- I made a career out of it.
(laughing)
- Way to turn that around.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
I embarrassed myself in
front of Meryl Streep,
in front of the nation.
I didn't know people were filming.
And I didn't know she was gonna be there
and I, yeah, she's probably scared of me.
- No.
- It's fine.
It's fine.
- Everything's fine.
- But I think something we have in common,
I didn't really get to talk to you
'cause we had the teachers there
and everybody was.
I think we're very similar in
a sense of body positivity.
- Yeah.
- And I love that about you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- I think it's the greatest.
We all come,
different colors, different
shades, different sizes.
Even we're all different sizes
at different points in our lives,
and that's okay.
- Yeah.
- And I think, especially
for women in this business,
it's so important to have people
that are really confident and
comfortable in their skin.
And I'm just, have you
always been that way?
Just curious.
- You know, I think
it's an ongoing battle.
I think that every woman
can probably attest to that
but it was, I don't usually
do New Year's resolutions
but this year I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to resolve
to not speak negatively
about my body to anybody
to anybody else or to myself.
(audience applauding)
Because I had this thought that I was,
I could tell you 25 things right now
that I hate about my body
but I could probably also
tell you 25 that I like.
- Yeah!
- So I was like,
I'm just gonna focus on
the things that I like
and I'm not gonna focus
on the other things.
And what's amazing is
that it disarms people.
So there'll be times in conversation,
I'll be like, "Well you know,
"I have the greatest
butt in the business."
And people are like, "Oh my gosh."
(laughing)
And then I just don't talk negatively
about myself anymore.
- I love that.
- And so, I put up a bikini
post, I was in Hawaii.
And I put up a post
of myself in a bikini--
- First of all,
I saw your bikini post.
And if I look like that in a bikini,
I'd post it too.
You look really really good.
- Well, thank you.
But for me, it was like,
I would never normally
wear something that tiny.
I would never normally post that publicly.
But it was important to me
because I feel fabulous
and it was such a,
just making that small mindset shift,
even if I think something negative,
the fact that I'm not saying it out loud
has made such a difference.
- Yeah!
- And I really can't
encourage people more.
'Cause listen!
- Oh my god, that's my worst.
I love self-deprecation.
- Me too.
- I'm failing.
- No, I'm the same way but you know what,
I'm the same way because a lot of comedy
comes from self-deprecation.
But I was like, you know what,
there's lots of things about
myself I can make fun of
that don't involve my appearance.
- Yeah.
- So many.
- Oh, I have a lot of those too.
I'm not like,
I don't just pick one.
- Yeah, you too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- So many personality flaws.
- Now I feel I can be
part of this conversation.
- Oh yeah, get in here.
- Yeah, yeah.
Oh man.
- Sure!
- This is something I love though.
And I'm curious if you
ever had a cake like this.
You had a butt cake.
- Yeah.
So I was--
- What?
(laughing)
- So two years ago for my birthday.
Wait.
Just wait for it.
- You didn't see the butt,
Jerry.
- He's gonna move back over
in about 30 seconds.
- Yeah.
- A couple years ago,
I was throwing this big girls party
in Palm Springs for my birthday,
and I was like,
"Oh, I've never had a bachelorette party.
"Should I get a fun
bachelorette-type cake?
"Maybe some male anatomy?"
And then I was like, "You know what, no."
"I'm gonna celebrate my anatomy."
So I had a picture taken
of my butt in the phone.
(Kelly laughing)
And I sent it to a baker
and they made a cake in
the likeness of my butt.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Oh my god!
- See, what'd I tell ya?
What'd I tell ya?
- [Kelly] Hey, Jerry.
Have you ever done a butt cake?
- [Jerry] Well are we
gonna get to eat some?
- Oh, there's the cake.
They're showing a picture of the cake.
- Where's the cake?
(laughing and applauding)